hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
today let's take a look at everything we
need or want to know about the next
Nexus so this is the current Galaxy
Nexus right here even though it's almost
about a year old now it is a very good
phone for the price you can get it
directly from Google at play.google.com
it's a great device the next Nexus
doesn't exist yet but based on a couple
of the shortcomings of this Galaxy Nexus
there are some things that we want for
the next one those are things to expect
isn't all that long which is what's
gotten some people to spread this rumor
about having like a Galaxy Nexus Plus
which is a minor like incremental
upgrade to the Galaxy Nexus but there's
literally no point for Google to do that
I know some other companies like to do
that but there's no point for Google to
do that so let's take a look at the list
first of all the OS Android 4.1.1 is the
latest version of Android and the Galaxy
Nexus runs out just fine
I have a feeling that the latest Nexus
isn't going to launch with another
drastic upgrade jelly beans relatively
new I think it's going to see something
like Android 4.1.2 jelly bean so I don't
launch with jelly bean not the next
version which might be like key lime pie
or something a larger battery would be
awesome the Galaxy Nexus comes with an
1800 milliamp hour battery
stock that lasts barely a full day for
most people you can get an extended
battery for a 2100 milliamp hour battery
and that can get people comfortably
through the day but it still doesn't
have the best battery life that it could
have I'm thinking that the new body of
the Galaxy Nexus even if it doesn't have
a bigger screen might just be a little
bit taller to accommodate a bigger
battery something more along the lines
of 2400 milliamp hours and speaking of
that body I don't think it's going to be
all that drastically different you can
see the lineup has changed quite a bit
for the Nexus in the past couple of
years but I think it might be a slightly
larger screen just to keep up with the
current times I'd say about 4.7 inches
which is just a tiny bit bigger and
again like I said a slightly taller body
to accommodate a bigger screen and a
bigger battery now the camera on the
back one of the big reasons I've used
the galaxy s3 over the Galaxy Nexus is
the significantly better camera I share
a lot of media pictures and while this
takes great photos and great video the
Galaxy Nexus takes pretty good video and
ok photos it's a 5 megapixel sensor and
I'm expecting to see something more
along
of an eight or higher megapixel sensor
and overall just a better quality sensor
and better glass in the next nexus
camera my official guess would be 8
megapixels but 12 isn't totally out of
the picture but other than that there's
not a whole lot you see this design I
hope that the next Nexus has as clean
and as beautiful and as sculpted a
design as the current Galaxy Nexus as
this is probably the best-looking phone
out there right now at least in my
opinion no branding whatsoever on the
front and the back maybe it could use
some work by some people but the front
is perfect and I don't think anything
needs to change about it again maybe a
bigger screen but it's pretty much going
to be a similar form factor don't expect
it to be like a Galaxy Note or anything
crazy like that now it would be nice if
google gave Verizon just a little kick
you know some of the carriers aren't
pushing the newest version of Android
jelly bean to the Galaxy Nexus as they
hold now that's the advantage of buying
it straight from Google is you can get
the latest version of Android
immediately but for those of us who are
on contracts with carriers they'll be
nice if Google gave them a little kick
and said hey push it out
or if they just handle that process all
themselves which is more difficult than
it sounds now who will make it my guess
is going to be Samsung again now some
people have said Motorola might make it
I think the next next next will be made
when Google vertically integrates and
takes advantage of their purchase of
Motorola Mobility but some people have
been saying a sous-sous made the Nexus 7
which was their tablet but if you think
about it Asus doesn't really make very
many good Android phones a lot of the
reasons why Google pick Samsung is
because they dominated Android phones
the year before
right now Samsung is still doing very
well Asus makes great dominating tablets
so they take some Asus for the tablet
and they're probably going to pick
Samsung again for the next Nexus there
is a rumour however that there's going
to be multiple nexuses launched by
different carriers and by different
manufacturers at the same time and this
rumor has some nice credibility actually
there could be an LG Nexus there could
be a Samsung Nexus maybe an HTC Nexus I
don't know exactly the manufacturers but
there could be multiple nexuses launched
at the same time all with the latest
version of Android stock Android no
skins on top of them and the updates
pushed from Google if I had to guess
right now I'd say
that is what's going to happen but the
main one that is sold in the Google Play
Store will probably be the Samsung one
internally I don't have a whole wrong
laundry list of things I just hope that
they adopt the new two gigabytes of RAM
that Samsung seems to be pushing as a
standard most phones now have one gig of
ram released smartphones anyway so two
gigs of ram is the next like upgrade and
a quad-core processor is of course
something we like to see on the list and
other than that just make it powerful
when will it come out it has to come out
before the holiday season or at least
like right before it
my guess is December 3rd it's just a
date I happen to like so is that a good
list or what I mean there's a lot of
things that we could expect to come out
of the next Nexus like some crazy rumors
have been floating around even some
weird looking mock-ups that some people
actually seem to believe are the next
Nexus but I also don't know what it's
going to be called I keep saying next
Nexus as if that's not a tongue-twister
but it totally is you should try saying
it like 12 times fast if you have
something else to add to the list you
can feel free to leave it down in the
comment section below
right below that like button on this
video and go ahead and share this video
to other people who have all sorts of
questions that I get about the next
Nexus yeah there you go a lot of people
were wondering if they should hold off
on buying a Galaxy Nexus now with
jellybean because the next one will be
coming out but I I think you have about
three more months before the next Nexus
comes out I'm gonna say December and
yeah we'll see how that goes so either
way thanks for watching this video if
you enjoyed it like I said feel free to
give it a thumbs up and I'll talk to you
guys very soon in a video that you are
not going to want to miss see you on
Monday thanks
you